يقول عنوان مجلة
وول ستريت هذا بينما تنضم كامالا هاريس إلى
حجم وول ستريت في بايدن في الإغاثة
، وقال بيل دالي رئيس موظفي الرئيس السابق لأوباما
الآن مع
ويلز فارجو في اقتباس لمجلة وول ستريت
أعتقد أن هاريس شخص عقلاني معقول
عمل في  النظام هل
هي تقدمية ، نعم ،
هل هي شخص يريد
حرق المبنى ، لا أعتقد أنها تريد
تقوية المبنى إذا كان وول ستريت يولد
الصعداء مع تسمية كامالا هاريس
على التذكرة ،
ما الذي تفعله بيرني ساندرز جيدًا
كل ما في وسعه لهزيمة
دونالد ترامب كان يقوض الديمقراطية الأمريكية ،
لقد كذب دونالد ترامب على الشعب الأمريكي
مرارًا وتكرارًا في كل قضية
دونالد ترامب الذي لا يدعم
الاستمرار في
هذه الشيكات التكميلية البالغ عددها 600 والحفاظ عليها والتي
يحتاجها العمال بشدة أو 1200
شيك عمل كثير منهم.  العائلات بحاجة إلى
دونالد ترامب الذي يريد التخلص من 32
مليون شخص من التأمين الصحي في
ذلك الوقت  مرحبًا دونالد ترامب الذي لا
يدرك حتى
العلم من حيث الوباء أو في
تغير المناخ ،
لذا فإن ما ستفعله بيرني ساندرز هو
القيام بكل ما في
وسعي لهزيمة دونالد ترامب لانتخاب جو بايدن
وبعد
سيطرة الديمقراطيين على مجلس الشيوخ  والبيت
وجو هو الرئيس ،
سنبذل قصارى جهدنا
لتعبئة الناس من
أجل أجندة تقدمية ، لكن هذه ليست
قضية معقدة
يجب هزيمة دونالد ترامب ،
ويجب انتخاب بايدن وبعد تلك
الانتخابات
سنذهب  نفعل كل ما في وسعنا
لإحراز تقدم للنضال من أجل أجندة تقدمية